Ukrainian military officials say the
capital city of chieve is under attack
this morning Air Raid Sirens wailed
across the city today after Russia
launched several missiles targeting
critical infrastructure no word yet on
any casualties or the extent of the
damage it is the first time Russia has
attacked the capital since New Year's
Day Russia's military has been focused
on Fierce fighting in the East after the
Kremlin claim control of the salt mine
town of solidar but Ukraine has denied
the Takeover and claims it's just part
of Russian President Putin's propaganda
machine Deborah patter reports from Kiev
it's one of the bloodiest battles since
the War Began
Russia claims it's taken control of
solidar Ukraine disputes this its forces
have been holding out against a
ferocious Russian Onslaught led by
Wagner Mercenaries
the fight for the small salt mining town
in eastern Ukraine has assumed an
outsized significance but a win in
solidar would give Vladimir Putin his
first Victory after months of
humiliating losses
this man was instrumental evgeny
pregosian the leader of the Russian
mercenary group Wagner
volunteer in a Russian prison recruiting
convicts to fight on the front line in
solidar and Bahamut in this video
pregozian congratulates the first batch
of returning Fighters you've finished
your contract with honor he said Don't
drink don't use drugs or rape women
Ukrainian military analyst Alexander
kovalenko says arming hardened criminals
has created the risk of even more
Battlefield atrocities
with those convicts can commit any crime
he thinks necessary to win the battle he
said all he's done is build a blood
business already he told us they've seen
an increase in war crimes in the areas
where Wagner is fighting
has been outspoken in his criticism of
senior Russian military leaders and
their Battlefield losses including
Putin's newly appointed general in
charge of the war Valerie garasimov for
CBS Saturday morning Deborah patter
Keith